we begin with Tiger Woods as he gears up
for his legal fight with X Erica Herman
I spoke to his former flame Rachel
yucatell who had this warning for
Tiger's ex
[Music]
what would be your message to Erica she
has an uphill battle in front of her you
were quoted as saying she's up against a
machine what did you mean by that you
know Tiger's team is very he's got a lot
of money and she's just one person so so
she's got a lot of work to do she wants
to prove a case Eric is suing for 30
million dollars in pushing to invalidate
the NDA tiger had her sign the golf
Champ's former flame Rachel yucatal
knows all about those kinds of
agreements what about you and tiger are
you going to get married to Tiger
she was at the center of Tiger's
cheating scandal in 2009. I was
unfaithful I had affairs I cheated and
more than a decade later she still
haunted by her decision to sign a
30-page NDA the lesson that I learned is
that no amount of money gets your life
back I'd rather be poor and homeless
than have to go through what I endured I
lost all sense of respect self-worth
friends family in return for her Silence
about her affair with tiger Rachel got
five million dollars and a promise of 1
million annually for three years to
follow are you sorry that you took that
money oh 100 the money was nothing
compared to what you know I got in
return the hatred the then um do you
feel bad about Tiger's wife
what were some of the things that
happened to you when it was believed
that you were getting close to violating
your NBA or could violate your interview
I mean just me becoming quote-unquote
famous was breaking my NBA are you gonna
be an actress in Hollywood
anytime I did one thing that I was
literally written about I was breaking
the NDA which was crazy I remember I it
was an article in TMZ that I was
pregnant that was a violation of my NDA
I would get a letter every time I was in
the paper you have a 10 year old
daughter now how hard has that been with
explaining to your daughter what
happened well that's funny Kevin I don't
have to explain anything to her because
it's all over the media right Rachel's
ready to move on she's pitching a book
and launching a podcast called
misunderstood all about Second Chances
and life after being reduced to a
headline I've had to fight for my place
in life one person at a time to get them
to realize who I was because I'm so
misunderstood because of a ridiculous
thing that happened 14 years ago
[Music]